gilbert best us au travail et aux
[Rires]
personnes âgées m'a sauté suis hyper
angoisses et dudu j'ai le vertige et
tout le temps oui gilles si tu ne vas
pas sauter mais ce n'est pas mon sourire
lutins c'est mon rêve d'aller en laponie
donc je vais faire un attentat y aura
d'autres sélections faire autant a pas
eu lieu
j'ai sous les yeux de micros moi je vois
des enfants qui quelque part réalisé un
rêve se penchent ne pose pas la question
de savoir si oui ou non un jour ou
l'autre ils feront un disque si oui ou
non ils vont faire ce métier ils sont
juste heureux pour ça
c'est pas pour faire à l'heure dé jeu
1-0 goudé pour faire cuire des haricots
alors on n'est pas abattu pnr manger
l'eau fini donc voilà c'est vrai que
venez vite filé vite pour toi ces
raisons je vraiment j'adore ce programme
voilà alors mais vous mais vous mais
vous étiez le premier a vilipendé ce
programme et pendant que sa femme est
programmé parce que cyril en dit du bien
maintenant vous lécher ce programme mais
c'est scandaleux ce programme castaldi
vous savez très bien que dans ce livre
vous taisez vous j'ai la parole mais
trois fois dans l'émission donc ma mère
dépasse
[Applaudissements]
des bordels de la cub est directement en
cube est avec toi la cuvette des
toilettes
on va aller jusqu'à un ingénieur du son
pour remettre le micro de fil à parce
que merci merci c'est que s'il vous
plaît merci merci xavier des gilles
dormait j'allais vous réveillez vous
allez voir joey starr juste devant vous
vous allez pouvoir vous réconciliez vous
allez pouvoir communiquer ensemble à mon
signal est simplement à mon signal en un
an
vous allez le prendre dans vos bras pour
vous réconcilier c'est ça commence
maintenant
gill qui a été programmé juste avant au
nom qualia tuerie star devant vous mais
joey pour donner la venelle et xavier
mettez-vous c'est très compliqué pour
moi rené delaunay le dans vos bras c'est
très compliqué de jouer j'ai failli
arrêter la télé à cause de toi je savais
plus et ses loisirs essayer ces contrées
que c'est vous c'est vous qui m'avez un
conduirait pas porter plainte et où john
f
tu es venu c'est un gilet pour y faire
la bise maintenant pour voyez vous pas
tout est venu
vous regardez dans cabaret 80% des
artistes
[Applaudissements]
je préviens ça fait des mois que dit me
taire et faire l'écho se faire entendre
votre victoire est là où vous verrez
tous les horizons et moi je veux plus te
voir tourner à vous
[Applaudissements]
ces lots sur ce plateau il n'a pas
compris qu'on le voulait plus lui gilles
oui mais qu'est ce tu vas dire un petit
bourg nous partir
[Rires]
j'étais terrifiée par le vide dit pas
les trucs comme ça mais moi je sais de
la morale est allé pêcher bien sûr bull
mais que ça qu'il est mignon là et les
boules
[Applaudissements]
il ya ceux là sont jeunes qui sort de
l'oeil nous a dit ça s'hérite pas dire
si j'emmerde tout le monde peut breton m
[Applaudissements]